[Music]
on this monday night
kids and covid19 new research shows how
children carry the coronavirus as
parents face the dilemma of sending
their kids
back to school or keeping them at home
the plan feels very unsafe
plus an australian state's new curfew
deemed critical
issa is careening toward the carolinas
you should take this storm
seriously preparing for a storm surge
during a covet 19
surge app apprehension the data tick
tock could grab
from your phone and why trump wants it
out of chinese hands
and expanding underwater it'd be
incredible time for us
the campaign to convert an eyesore into
a tourist attraction
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
with the august long weekend now behind
us a new and
very different school year is fast
approaching
across the country provinces have
unveiled plans for getting kids
back into classrooms though many parents
and students are
still wondering how it will work and
whether it's safe
in tonight's top story heather york's
west digs into the latest research on
kids and coveted 19
and how public health officials are
trying to manage the risks
send children back to class and risk
infection
keep them at home and risk their
education or emotional health
it's a decision facing parents right now
that appears to be
no win in alberta more than 6 000
parents have signed an open letter
voicing concerns about the province's
plan
for getting kids back to class if you
think about the fact that a lot of
people have asthma if you think about
the fact that a lot of people have heart
disease if you think about the fact that
a lot of children see their grandparents
all of these things create
vulnerabilities from the get-go
and so it seems very
difficult to simply say that we will
just see how it goes
schools will be operating in uncharted
territory relying on research that is
still incomplete with new data emerging
almost
every day i think all these studies a
lot of them contradict each other and so
it does make it really confusing
last week a study published in the
journal of the american medical
association
found young kids with coveted 19 carried
more virus in their nose and throats
than older kids and adults
but that may not mean kids are easily
able to spread that virus around
i think that little kids young kid
children are not
coughing as forcefully they may not have
as many symptoms so maybe they're not
really coughing as much
in australia where schools remained open
during the first wave
data published monday suggests that when
physical distancing and hygiene measures
are in place
the risk of transmission is low after
looking at data from 25 schools between
january and april
researchers found that although 27
children or teachers went to school
while infectious
out of a possible 1448 contacts
the virus only spread to an additional
18 people
of course there are social and emotional
risks to keeping kids out of school as
well
what we don't want to do is then have a
cohort of kids that have missed
really important parts of their
education which are
necessarily for for most of these age
groups
building blocks for their later
educational success
it's why many provinces are determined
to get kids back to class
even as what is known about the virus
continues to change
there is still a lot of evidence from
international sources and other
jurisdictions
that we are carefully reviewing our
guidance will be updated in the coming
weeks when we complete
this evidence review so though the
school year is just weeks away
back to school plans could still change
by the time kids are ready for their
first day
heather urex west global news calgary
more than six months into this pandemic
the picture around the world remains
grim
the spread of the virus is accelerating
in a number of countries
in the span of just four days one
million more people have been infected
with coven 19.
that brings the total number of global
infections to more than 18 million
and more than 690 000 people have died
the world health organization warns
there's still a long way to go in this
crisis
and countries must strictly enforce
public health measures
to get infections under control we all
hope to have a number of effective
vaccines however
there is no silver bullet at the moment
and there might never be for now
stopping outbreaks comes down to the
basics of public health and disease
control
in australia authorities are taking
aggressive steps to try to get a major
outbreak under control after weeks of
spiking case numbers
they've declared a state of disaster in
the state of victoria
with that come a series of sweeping new
restrictions
for a region that's already been in
lockdown mode for weeks
redmond shannon reports on the shock and
awe tactics in a region
that had been one of the world's great
success stories
melbourne australia's second largest
city deserted
under a new nighttime curfew and now the
state of victoria says
all non-essential businesses will close
starting wednesday night
this six week period is absolutely
critical
we have got to make decisions uh very
difficult decisions but we've got to er
on the side of doing everything we
possibly can to drive these case numbers
down
if there is such a thing as a second
wave then victoria is a case study
australia had all but eliminated
infections until the new spike a month
ago
it's winter down under and similar sized
cities in canada and elsewhere
might well look to melbourne to see how
a second lockdown
works out we'll see the effect of
universal mask wearing
in the numbers in the week ahead and
ongoing
we'll see the effect of these
restrictions in the following week
plans for an australian travel bubble
with new zealand
now on the back burner that will be a
long way off
given what they're experiencing right
now the philippines is experiencing
an even more serious situation we're
waging a
losing battle against copies 19 and we
need to draw up
a consolidated deputy plan of action
president rodrigo duterte bowing to
pressure from medics to act
imposing a two-week lockdown on 25
million people
in greater manila starting tuesday i
fully
understand why your health workers
would like to ask for such a time out
period
they have been in the front lines for
months
and are exhausted new infections have
risen
sharply since the first lockdown eased
two months ago
it would seem to me that in most
countries that have experienced intense
community transmission
the way out is long and it requires a
sustained
commitment the world health organization
says it's also committed to finding the
precise origins of covet 19.
it has started efforts in china to find
an answer
and more work will be needed with
beijing's cooperation
redmond shannon global news london
pakistan's government has ordered a
countrywide lockdown despite recording
one of its lowest
daily infection rates grocery stores and
pharmacies are allowed to stay
open along with mosques and churches
providing people where masks and
adhere to physical distancing the
lockdown which will be in effect for two
weeks follows the muslim holiday
of eid al-hada it's to help avoid
asserting cases that occurred in june
after eid
all fitter a norwegian cruise company
has apologized and canceled
upcoming trips after a major outbreak on
one of its ships
so far at least 41 people who are aboard
the ms royald amundsen
have tested positive for the virus
there's fear dozens of coastal
communities in norway
may have been exposed as the ship
stopped at multiple ports during trips
in july
in a statement today the ceo of the
cruise company says he's sorry for
mistakes that contributed
to the outbreak and there are reports
tonight
another cruise ship has been hit by an
outbreak according to authorities in
french polynesia
a passenger on the paul gauguin cruise
ship in tahiti has tested positive
the roughly 340 other passengers and
crew members
are now reportedly being tested and kept
in their cabins
turning now to the united states where
in the midst of a pandemic
millions of people are bracing for what
could be a devastating storm
after skirting past florida tropical
storm issa east is picking up strength
as it turns toward the u.s east coast
it's expected to make a direct hit
tonight on the carolinas
potentially as a full-blown hurricane
before heading north
reaching canada later this week
forecasters say the track and strength
of the storm could change in the coming
days
as for tonight they're warning coastal
communities to be prepared for flash
floods
life-threatening storm surges and
possibly even tornadoes
jackson proskow has more on the threat
posed by issa east
and what people are doing to prepare in
the carolinas they're getting ready for
whatever isaias may bring
you've got to be prepared for the worst
and hope for the best the storm is on
track for a direct strike
landfall will bring high winds heavy
rain and more than a meter of storm
surge in some areas
i think it's going to be a typical
rainstorm i don't think there's any
really reason to worry or
evacuate but along the coast torrential
rains are expected from washington d.c
into maine in new york they're putting
up sandbags and temporary flood barriers
in lower manhattan
there's a risk of widespread flash
flooding and downed trees
we want people to stay safe and stay in
and stay home in a tale of dueling
disasters the worst impacts will be felt
in states where the kovit 19 pandemic is
surging we know the pandemic
has dominated everyone's attention these
last few months
but north carolina emergency managers
have been carefully planning for the
storm response
in a covid19 environment in this new
reality
anyone staying in a storm shelter will
be screened for covid19 symptoms
masks and physical distancing are a must
florida which was spared a direct hit
shut down state-operated testing sites
for days as a precaution
while coastal hospitals moved
coronavirus patients inland
measures that may be needed again soon
we're more prepared now than
for the next one you know we'll get
better and better and that's that's the
goal is to always get better
the storm is part of an extremely active
year in the atlantic
izaias is the ninth named system it's
rare to be this deep into the alphabet
this early
and hurricane season is just getting
started
jackson proskow global news washington
nearly 8 000 people are under an
evacuation order in southern california
where the so-called apple fire has
exploded in size
thousands of firefighters are battling
the flames in hot dry conditions
more than ten thousand hectares have
been charred and the fire is only five
percent contained
tonight investigators have confirmed a
vehicle malfunction
ignited the fire it began friday when
two fires merged in the mountains east
of los angeles
the clock is ticking for tick tock's
chinese owner
coming up the u.s president's ultimatum
and the vast
access the app can have to your phone
plus eliminating a communication barrier
the face mask that could make life
easier for the hearing
impaired and new fears tonight about the
health of a former pope
there's some big political news tonight
out of newfoundland and labrador
we now know who will replace dwight ball
as premier
the province's liberal party has
announced andrew fury has won the race
to become its next leader
he's a doctor and charity founder who's
never held public office before
in february ball abruptly announced
plans to resign
his departure comes as newfoundland and
labrador deals with both the pandemic
and a major financial crisis
with the provincial deficit skyrocketing
after being sworn in fury is required by
law to call an election
within a year despite losing its bid for
a seat on the united nations security
council
canada will provide support to u.n
peacekeeping missions in africa
for another year the defense department
confirms a military transport plane
which has been based out of uganda since
2019
will continue its role transporting
critical supplies and personnel
many saw this promise as an attempt by
the liberal government to bolster its
bid for a two-year seat
on the u.n security council but canada
lost to norway and ireland
on the first ballot u.s president donald
trump risks alienating young voters
ahead of november's election if he goes
ahead with a ban
on the popular video app tick tock the
app mostly used by people under 20 is
owned by chinese company
bite dance trump claims tick tock poses
a national security threat
because of its ties to china and is
threatening to ban it
if it's not sold to a u.s firm by
september 15th
and one american tech company is ready
to snap it up
here's mike trolley
you either understand tiktok's
popularity or you don't
users post short videos of just about
anything including lip syncing and
dancing
half of all canadians under the age of
25 have downloaded the app
along with over 800 million users around
the world
and just as the us accused tech giant
huawei of sharing user information with
the chinese government
it's now pointing the finger at tick
tock it's a great asset but it's not a
great asset in the united states unless
they have
the approval of the united states so it
will close down on september 15th
unless microsoft or somebody else is
able to
buy it for its part tick tock maintains
all its data is stored in the us
and inaccessible to the chinese
government but it's not just the us
that's concerned
india banned the app a month ago so how
is it that
what we put on our phones is a national
security issue well users give tick tock
access to
a long list of things including audio
and video your address book your gps
location as well as all of your network
and wi-fi connections put another way
everything you put on your phone
it now knows it can be sold on the open
market it can be sold
on the dark web because every piece of
data has a value
and ultimately that information can and
likely will be used against us so
we think that we're invulnerable we're
not even if we're not famous
our data can be used against us in some
capacity so now microsoft has 45 days to
make a deal which has been reported to
be worth as much as 50 billion dollars
but even if it doesn't tick-tock won't
go away
the app isn't going to summarily go dark
and we're not all suddenly going to get
cut off from it it'll simply be more
difficult for new users to get involved
or for the user base to grow and by then
another platform will have launched to
feed our insatiable appetite
for posting videos mike relay global
news toronto
still ahead why face masks are hindering
communication for the hearing impaired
a german newspaper is reporting former
pope benedict is seriously ill
according to benedict's biographer the
93-year-old is extremely frail
suffers from painful shingles and his
voice is barely audible
but the vatican says his condition is
not particularly
worrying benedict resigned from the
papacy in 2013 for health reasons
he was the first pope in 600 years
to do so more than 1.3 million canadians
have hearing disabilities
that's according to statistics canada
and nearly one quarter report
they read lips to communicate now
they're having to navigate a world where
face masks are being worn
to slow the spread of covet 19. as
crystal commansing reports the hearing
impaired community
is advocating for wider use of a special
mask
designed to help meet their needs masks
are a part of daily life in the uk
and mangaisa tarsin is all too aware of
the rules
standing waiting for the moment someone
speaks to her
now fills her with dread
she says for me it's so important it
doesn't matter if i'm communicating with
another deaf person or
hearing person lip reading is incredibly
important
if someone is signing to me and they're
not using lip patterns and mouth
movements
it's impossible to understand so tarzan
is the director of empowering
deaf society she understands the
importance of
masks but wants everyone else to
understand
how they and other face coverings are
leading to millions of people
feeling excluded from society it's
created
just not only communication issues but
very much mental health
issues there's a lot of angst there's a
lot of frustration
there's a lot of fear in an effort to
address those feelings the canadian hard
of hearing association is looking to the
federal health minister
to advocate for wider use of clear
plastic face shields
they remove the barrier for those who
need to read lips
while keeping people safe there are also
masks with clear panels
to raise awareness paramedic danny
hughes took to social media
recently to show people how he's using
his phone to bridge the divide
that some of our patients and service
users
rely on lip reading to communicate and
wearing a mask
makes lip reading almost impossible
zadarson like her canadian counterpart
wants the government to advocate for
more clear mass to be produced and used
allowing her to go back to doing regular
tasks
without heightened anxiety crystal
commansing
global news london
i'm alexa mclean off the coast of
lunenburg nova scotia where there's a
new push to make
these waters an international diving
destination
we'll tell you how next on global
national
nova scotia is often described as
canada's ocean playground
and has become known for a unique
underwater tourist attraction
hmcs saginai was intentionally sunk to
create a marine park for divers
it has been at the bottom of the
atlantic ocean for 26 years
now one group is working to expand this
artificial reef
alexa mclean explains
about a 45-minute steam from the
waterfront of lunenburg nova scotia
lies an underwater attraction these
divers hope will one day
double in size an artificial reef poised
for expansion
further securing canada's place as an
international
diving destination we already have one
amazing shipwreck out there
and to add what is a former navy dive
vessel
if we could add that close by you could
have a weekend of diving here in
lunenburg
it'd be incredible time for us
in july 1994 hundreds of people flocked
to these waters
to watch the purposeful sinking of hmcs
sagine
a former royal canadian navy destroyer
the steel warship now lies on the bottom
of the ocean
an artificial reef home to countless
species
of marine life and a truly unique diving
attraction there's nothing like dropping
underwater
going down 60 70 80 feet and all of a
sudden seeing
a military frigate just kind of coming
in coming to focus
now a group of divers and artificial
reef experts hope to give the saginay
some company for 20 years the now
derelict hmcs
cormorant has been docked in nova scotia
at the port of bridgewater
it's been falling apart for years at one
point
even partially sinking now the canadian
coast guard is collecting proposals to
have it towed away
and scrapped but this group wants the
cormorant turned into another artificial
reef
this could be a great solution to get it
off the port there
and into the ocean spawning marine life
and local divers
work is underway to formally pitch the
coast guard
strict environmental standards have to
be met in order to reef a ship
we tagged along on this mission as they
scout it for potential safe sites
next to the saginai it needs to be nice
and level
with no great amount of light that could
be disturbed
the team believes it's found a perfect
spot now
they hope to pave the way for the
cormorant to sit alongside the saginay
as a picture-perfect pair alexa mclean
global news
lunenburg nova scotia and that is global
national for this monday
i'm robin gill tonight your canada is
alberta's jasper national park and the
old moline lake boathouse built
in 1928. thank you for watching donna
friesen will be back here tomorrow
have a great night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you